okay good evening ladies and gentlemen
welcome everyone in audience it is now
called plus six so we shall get underway
momentarily and if I can ask before we
actually start if members of our both
our panel and the audience could turn
their phones to silent
I appreciate there may be some urgent
need to use one's phone but if we could
have them on silent so it doesn't
disturb the meeting this is a meeting of
the council's planning committee it is
not an open forum and so only members of
the public or parish councils are
registered speak will be able to speak
again I would ask members of the
audience if they could respect that and
allow the smooth running of this
committee so that members can make their
decisions we are being recorded for
viewing at a later date again if you
would like your face either pixelated or
removed from the recordings if after the
meeting you speak to a variety
specialist they walk make sure you we do
that okay I'm launched our officers
starting from my far right to our very
quickly introduce themselves Rotter
chambers legal services mina mac legal
services committee services
Traci Humphreys on the implementation
team leader in planning Louise Coleman
Senior Planner Thompson plan Louise
Casey planner Joseph Brooke father
Sara McPherson planner marvelous thank
you very much Trey do you have a very
specific role tonight if you could share
that with us that would be great
Thank You chairman yes I'm the planning
manager for tonight's meeting my role is
to provide impartial advice to clarify
any planning issues that arise and to
assist members in decision taking in so
doing I am bound by the Royal Town
Planning Institute code of Professional
Conduct and for the avoidance of doubt
planning committee members are not bound
by advice from officers or by their
recommendations
thank you Jim thank you very much okay
do we have any apologies please yes
Sherman
we have apologies from councillor
Kendall and apologies from counselor
Eden for whom comes that hinge the
Seraphim is very kindly substituting
thank you very much and welcome to you
do we have any disclosures of interest
from the committee please yes I should
be sprinkles a ward member on the first
item okay lovely anything else okay
January are you all happy that they are
true and fair reflection can I sign them
after this meeting yes agreed nervous
thank you very much
okay looking through our applications
now and as you've heard contentious
elephant is speaking on our first
application which is 1901 6:01 ful and
with him moving away from the table it
does make our committee on the core it
so what I propose is that we move that
down the list of items to see tonight
until councillor Dixon arrives I hope
that's okay with members of the
committee yes yes I've spoken to the
speakers on that and they would confirm
that's okay so cancer I'm Seraphin if
you'd like to read take your seat and we
will be looking a venn sorry Louise I
hadn't conveyed that here yeah we're
looking then at number five application
1902 three one nine ful as land opposite
oak house in Chesterton
Louise Casey is our presenting officer
Louise as soon as you're ready and there
is no rush over to you
Thank You chairman the application
amount for members seeks planning
permission for the construction of a
detached two-bedroom bungalow the
dwelling has been put forward as a local
needs dwelling so the application site
is identified by the black dot here and
it's situated within the village of
Chesterton the application site is
outlined here more clearly in red the
site comprises a rectangular path of
land situated within a wider paddock
there's an existing equestrians last
agricultural access which is in use by
the adjacent barn here and that's also
proposed to serve the new dwelling the
adjacent barn and the surrounding
paddock falls within the applicants
ownership so here we've got an aerial
view which just demonstrates the
relationship with the site and the
surroundings again we've got the
application site in red and now moving
on to the proposed and next we've got
the proposed floor plan so the dwelling
would be single-story with two bedrooms
and here we've got the proposed
elevations so it would be constructed in
brick beneath a tile roof so moving on
to images of the application site here
in this first image we've got a view
looking towards the site from the north
so the map to the right hand side here
should be used as a point of reference
with the yellow arrow indicating the
position where the photo has been taken
and traveling southwards along the old
gated Road in this photo we can see the
application site in relation to mill
house here which is the nearest
neighboring dwelling on the eastern side
of the old gated Road
and here we've got a photo of the
existing vehicle access
photo also demonstrates the sharp rise
in Lund levels which are on the eastern
side of the road coming to the left here
is the existing barn and panning to the
right we can see the land here rise up
towards where the dwelling would sit
this is just a similar photo just step
slightly backwards so you can see where
the dwelling was in relation to the road
side and here we've got the final photo
which is just viewing the site of the
dwelling in the opposite direction so to
conclude chest attorney's classes in all
of a settlement where new residential
development is restricted to small-scale
community-led schemes which would meet
an identified need by the local
community in this case the principle of
a single dwelling it's not accepted on
the site as it's not been satisfactorily
demonstrated that the proposal would
meet a clear identified local need and
also the applicant has not been found to
meet the definition of a local person
and additionally the proposal has not
been found to accord with the
established settlement pattern in the
area and neither would it protect the
surrounding open landscape so chairman
it's recommended planning permissions
refused for the reasons set out within
the report and there are no of this
Louise thank you very much we'll go
straight to our first speaker please who
is councillor Andy
Turner chairman of Cheston and Kingston
parish of meeting welcome councillors
Anna you have three minutes to speak and
if it remains seated afterwards we will
have questions from the panel so
whenever you're ready please thank you
the best parish considered this
application fully meets the local need
speed my period let me address the
precise wording of the SDC developments
SPD to support this application in
section 2.1 which states SDC actively
encourages communities to take the lead
in promoting high school students in
Section 2.2.1
there is reference to policy cs50 and
states
SCC will attach significant weight to
the fact that the Parish Council is
supportive of the LMS it goes on a
parish council can bring forward a
free-standing LMS at any time it is the
local community to discern what is best
approach is taking into account the
local circumstances the parish fully
supports its application additionally
all labor the properties are joining the
plan together to fully support the
application and have done so in writing
in Section two point two point two which
states the LMS must respond to an
identified need and Saints in
exceptional circumstances and need may
be identified outside a formal survey eg
for world references in section two
point two point where it states that an
LMS should be available to people with a
local connection to the point and as the
SPD states it is for the local community
to determine what constitutes a local
connection allow me to challenge the
planners interpretation for this
application problem or authority object
on the following basis local connection
only satisfies one of the criteria with
the SCC guidances safe parish councils
can decide that Steve's shouldn't be
just some identifier
[Music]
thirty seconds CS 5 and cs9 protected
land statement sensitive surround
setting directly opposite are for large
two and three-story houses all granted
permission last ten years the
recommendations by the planners is
discriminatory the price does not accept
this is an in congress format
development all the recently granted
permissions in the buildings within 50
meters of this application on a
different style and character you might
actually consider this application
favorably take very much comes to turn
our members do you have any questions no
I will ask a question you talked about a
local needs survey have you conducted a
formal survey
if you read the condition that is not
equally we have canvassed the parish
there will a drop-in session in
September organized by the applicant
it was unanimously accepted by all
parishioners that this application
should be great thank you very much
if there are no further questions thank
you very much for your important we have
no objectives listed to speak so we move
to the applicant now Mary Cobb welcome
so when you're comfortable and ready
again you have three minutes I'll give a
30-second warning and whenever you're
ready please start
can you right button can I just ask that
okay thank you and more particularly the
Parish Council and residents of
Chesterton for their unanimous support
can I just give you a very brief context
I purchased the landlady seven years ago
equestrian purposes during that period
in my partner has become increasingly
disabled and therefore it is become
increasing ly difficult to leave him in
order to look after the horses and work
from the land increased crime in the
area that's also being in eastern as
we've heard I was broken into in
December 2019 changing patterns in the
weather but also net but I need to visit
the land more frequently during the day
always twice per day often three times a
day in bad weather to attempt the
welfare of the horses journey is the top
can take
hazardous driving conditions therefore I
made the decision to consider applying
mission to build a single-story fully
accessible dwelling I firstly contacted
the planning department to arrange
please pre-planning advice which is a
service that is a unfortunately no
longer available however I was advised
by the duty officer to discuss the
application with the neighbors and the
parish council before making a formal
application I did so and received
unanimous support with reference to the
document development requirements SPD
general and local housing needs as to
local housing now locally planting
schemes mr. Turner has spoken about
support to the parish council and
responding to the event identifying need
I should like to address be available to
people with a local connection to the
parish I currently live in action which
is three miles away from trespassing I'm
alarmed for approximately four to five
hours of the day brasov reported at that
time I am working with the horses the
rest of the time is spent and working on
the land some of that work be classified
as maintenance
I have also developed the land in terms
of building a ménage providing
additional fencing stapling and shelter
for the horses
currently I must engaged in a commercial
activity but some very active in terms
of providing facilities threaten the
residents in the community he concluded
by the party of social functions grazing
for sheep livery for horses use of
menace for local horse owners location
of peasant fees for the local shoot
although I have not received any money
for these services there is an element
to bartering in terms of exchange of
favors as well as the desire to be
support
the community 37th in this way I believe
our fulfill the requirements working in
the parish if I lived on the land I
would potentially extend scope of work
to in clear breathing those ponies and
developing the truffle orchard part that
states that the need may be identified
outside the formal survey for example
welfare services I believe that the
welfare of my horses myself and my
disabled partner can be considered that
exception circumstances in conclusion I
would be willing to fulfill any
conditions linked to acceptance
acceptance of the application in terms
of design materials etc of the Bhangra
thank you for taking the time to
consider my preparation
thank you very much these guard members
do we have any questions no okay in that
case thank you very much now our board
member is not registered to speak so we
will move straight to a point of
clarification from officers members do
you have any questions for our officers
no councillor Perry can we just have
some clarification on the fact that the
parish chairman of the Parish Council
highlighted the fact that they didn't
need to have a local need survey that
that substantial support from the Parish
Council was significant evidence so in
terms of local needs schemes they
essentially need to meet four criteria
the first one is to have the support of
the local community which is our in the
report I agree that that is the case
second is to respond to an identified
needs so on that note in lack of any
neighbourhood plan or house needs survey
there is scope that a local news
dwelling can still be approved but there
needs to be sufficient and robust
evidence to demonstrate that there is an
identified local need and in terms of
the information that's come forward
whilst I accept that there's local
support
or that only meets the first criteria in
terms of having the support of the local
community responded to identified needs
a totally separate factor which hasn't
been addressed in this instance in terms
of the other two factors as well just
two out of the four the four third ones
to be available to a person who has a
local connection to the parish and the
fourth one is to be fourth to be
small-scale yes so what you're saying
Louise is that we've got one criteria
out of the four criteria that is not
included this the theme has been found
to fail against two of the criteria the
one criteria being it has not been found
to respond to identified need and the
other one is that we're not satisfied
that the applicant is considered to be a
local person that see it fails two out
of the four in our developments SPD part
s gives a lot of detail in terms of
local needs schemes and it says again in
lack of any housing needs survey or
neighbourhood plan which would enable
the parish to essentially set their own
rules in terms of what constitutes a
local person they set out five criteria
which the District Council usually use
they're sat out on the report so the
first one is they should be born in the
parish or whose parents are ordinary
residents in the parish at the time of
birth but as the second one is currently
lives in the parish or has done so for
the last 12 months
third is used to live in the parish or
did so for a continuous period of no
less than three years the fourth is that
they currently work in the parish and
have done so for at least the past
twelve months and for an average of not
less than 16 hours per week and the
fifth one is currently has a close
family member living in the pattern
done so for a continuous period of not
less than three years in communicating
with the applicant through the course of
the application I did raise this to them
and gave them the chance to demonstrate
that they met the criteria and the
applicant came forward and said that she
currently works in the parish but in
assessment of the evidence that come
forward we concluded that it doesn't
constitute work in terms of no
commercial activity she's not employed
in the parish and the works which he
carries out on the land would just be
maintenance works which would be part
and parcel owned in any patch of land
essentially can I just come back on the
work issue but if someone was setting up
a business as as as being self-employed
they would necessarily they would
necessary have to carry out some quite
extensive work on an unpaid basis
involving themselves in the community
promoting themselves in terms of what
they did wouldn't less would they not
necessarily be charging if they were
self-employed and they were setting
their their stall out and setting up for
a potentially a future business would
that not count as work I think it's
important to remember that from the
information that's been submitted it's
not been demonstrated that work is being
carried out on their site and when the
applicant spoke she did say that she's
not engaged in any commercial activity
on the site at the moment so when you
really classify work I mean presumably
charitable work or work for the local
community which isn't paid is that
classified as work still voluntary work
is that sort of ideas what the SPD when
it talks about work the word in is
currently works in the parish and has
done so for at least for at least the
past twelve months and for an average of
not less than
sixteen hours per week I think like I
said before in terms of the evidence
that's come forward we're not as
satisfied that the activities being
carried out on the land do constitute
work but it's not paid work it's not
first paid work it doesn't stipulate
that it has to be paid work in a parish
is there any clearly you're just
considering I don't have any from memory
but like I said before if the parish
were to have a neighborhood plan of
housing me survey they would then have
the ability to set their own criteria of
what constitutes a local person in
absence of that which the only thing we
have in front of us is what sets out on
the SPD and in terms of what sets out
the wording is lives in it refers to be
in the parish not on an adjoining parish
parish council highlighted the fact that
engagement was made with all the
villagers and parishioners would with
that in view of the size of Chesterton
which is a very which is a it's a
village because it's got a church rather
than a hamlet is am i right in thinking
that if if the parish council infers
that they they really carried out their
own sort of engagement with all the
villages on on that now I appreciate the
housing needs
a housing needs survey is carried out
usually by Warwickshire Rural Housing
Association in an official capacity I
just wonder what sort of weight a Parish
Council would have on the basis that it
said that it that the applicant has
engaged in conjunction with the Parish
Council on housing needs basis among
villages
I think the representative from the
parish counts all quite rightly pointed
out that having parish support does
weigh in the applications favour but
that is only one of the four criteria
they need to be considered and I think
it's worth mentioning which I haven't
mentioned already that I did consult the
development house in enabling officer
who works in the planning policy team on
this application and they came back
saying they had no prior knowledge of
this site the development and housing
enabler usually worked with work-to-rule
Housing Association to come up with
local needs schemes and he came back
saying he couldn't support the scheme
he's had no prior knowledge of it at all
okay do we have any more questions of
officers no in that case that's open up
the debate who would like to take the
lead on this range can surprise a team
to go this is a really difficult one
actually because I feel you know what we
have in front of us we have a very very
strong parish council support there are
absolutely no objections we have the
walk members support this is a very the
location of the proposed site is in an
appropriate location because it's right
in the center and it's small-scale
and yet we have 50% of the on the basis
that there are two criteria being met
and at the end of the day if if we were
minded to refuse this all the applicant
needs to do is to go back and carry out
a housing needs survey which will come
back in support of this application
clearly because you know she's as a
landowner she's entitled to actually she
would she would get one of the survey
questionnaires and on the basis of what
the parish council has said everybody
else in the village would also get the
survey to complete which would then
highlight there was a need for a small
two-bedroom facility in the village
because there are no no other facilities
currently available if there was a
2-bedroom or a bungalow available in the
village then I'm sure this is this is
clearly a reason why the applicant is
coming forward so I'm looking actually
for reasons to try and move this to
grant but I'm anxious that we we have
significant reasons to be able to do
that because really it's a technicality
there isn't a bit of paper there isn't a
housing needs survey that gives us a
tick box because if we had that I'm sure
the officers would have come back and
said grant so it's a situation where if
we refuse tonight we delay the whole
scenario by three months or whatever
time it takes
perhaps it's four months for the parish
council to instruct and get a housing
needs survey and we're back to we're
back here in four or five months
meantime you know we have someone with
clearly need with special circumstances
and now it all hinges on whether we feel
that the work she has been doing is
proper work or in fact because it's not
paid and it's not commercial it's not so
you know I minded to actually go for
grant on this particular one because I
think there are special circumstances
but I'm looking to see what other my
other colleagues feel as well to the
work being done on the land it's the
officers report to be carried out as
maintenance work in terms of the actual
passive land itself and I think I'm
right in saying the applicant said she
spends at least four hours a day there
that seems very excessive to carry out
maintenance work alone and I'd say that
having equestrian use and clearly use
which has a community function that does
exceed the minimum that you'd expect the
maintenance work for Land Management
just wide the fact that it's in an
agricultural setting so I think that the
what we've heard today in the very least
does suggest that this is more work than
just maintenance and I think that moves
do qualify the application to at least
have a local link to the pair attention
yes I agree with councillor Perry and
case there's no objections and it would
be a benefit to the small communities
and so we can't see any reason why to
refuse it
I remember reading somewhere to
something Tom Wiley's exchange of favors
when you do jobs for someone and they do
jobs for you back even though it's not
paid I'm sure that's classified as work
sure on that there's a lot of time spent
there if their work is done on a
charitable papers or volunteer basis
okay we have not had a formal proposal I
would just remind members that we are in
of course our judicial responsibility we
have a quasi judicial responsibility
here and of course we have to have clear
evidence to support our decision we're
told by our officers that that evidence
is lacking of course that means you
still have an opportunity to make a
decision based on what you see in front
of you if we're going to move forward I
do need to have a proposal from the
floor I would need reasons why we're
going against officers recommendation
just to add to that yeah I think members
should sort of bear in mind of the
precedent effects of their decisions as
well and the policy requires evidence of
local need rather than a personal need
so just bear that in mind obviously that
your decisions have a bearing on future
cases of this type
okay unless anyone wants to make finger
posle I will ask our planning manager to
quickly sum up what we've discussed thus
far sex ratio Thank You chairman yes we
do understand the points that members
raise and thank you to the speakers as
well for for explaining those so clearly
certainly in terms of the criteria that
we applied for that are set out in the
report in relation to those four
criteria which needs to be demonstrated
as officers in advising you we do feel
that all those four criteria are equally
important and on the basis of the
information we have at the moment only
two out of four of those criteria are
actually satisfied yes we do acknowledge
the parish councils support and we do
acknowledge that it's small-scale but in
terms of the evidence that we have in
front of us at the moment we don't feel
that it adequately demonstrates
identified need nor do we feel that it's
available to people with a local
connection to the parish as that policy
requires so unfortunately we don't feel
that the evidence base is sufficient at
the moment I would also add that members
will notice in the report that we have
two reasons for refusal in front of you
the second one is an unsafe impact one
and we are concerned you'll have noticed
from the photos the rising ground level
of the site and we do feel that they
propose location of the dwelling gives
rise to an acceptable impact in visual
appearance and landscape terms so we do
actually have two reasons to refusal for
members to consider in the balance so in
summary we do understand the applicants
perspective and we're not unsympathetic
to her needs but unfortunately on the
basis of your policies at the moment we
don't feel that we can support the
proposal and recommend approval
thank you very much counselor Perry
thank you chair
in the first instance but we do have to
bear in mind poses and precedent I would
live for I'm gonna have to propose to
refuse but I would like to recommend to
the parish council that they contact the
Warwickshire Rural Housing Association
and get a full housing needs survey done
because I think that all just as from my
point of view make sure that we are
acting fully in policy and I will go
forward to propose to refused with great
regret but I think we need to move this
application on Thank You councillor do I
have a seconder the exact same basis for
the same recommendation that I can't see
any other reason to refuse apart from
the technicalities which can be resolved
thank you you've had your opportunity to
speak thank you very much okay so we
have a proposal we have a seconder could
I please have a show of hands for those
in support of refusing in this
application I set out so therefore
committee resolves to refuse application
1902 3 1 9 ful I set out in the report
um members and members of our our
gallery we are desperately trying to get
hold of cancer Dixon so that we can
bring the first application forward
we're just going to take the couple of
minutes of the German to see if we can
get hold of them we have me able to so
far we may also be able to get another
member to come and sit in his place so
if we can take just two minutes and
we'll return that things
okay members and members of the gallery
regrettably we are going to have to
defer item it's not an item one item for
our studly land off reddit road instead
Lee I've just been informed that council
Dickson has suffered family bereavement
and it has as a result been unable to
attend we have tried to get hold of
other councillors to take his place at
short notice but unfortunately haven't
been able to so two members of the
public and speakers on that first item
I'm very sorry we are going to have to
defer to a later date you will be
notified when it's coming back to a
committee at a future date and if you
would like to take your leave you're
most welcome to do so now oh that you're
more than welcome watch the rest you got
another one coming up fabulous okay in
that case we will move to item 6 which
is application 1903 3 3/8 ful that's
green and farm and chips and on star my
presenting officer is
so Joe over to you when you're ready
thank you the site is located on the
outskirts of the rural village of
Willington as indicated by the black dot
for you as demonstrated by the button
for you the site is located on the
eastern edge and comprises approximately
naught point to 9 hectares of open land
the site is surrounded by countryside's
a northeast and southeast with
residential properties to the west and
southwest as you can see before us is a
google shot of the site so called by the
road confidence Minh and this is the
village of Willington the application
would be cited within that field for the
land is relatively flat and open a mix
of hedges and a post and rail fence
around the boundary of the site and
public footpath runs along the western
margin so in a north-south orientation
the application is seeking to construct
the four bedrooms two-story dwell in
with an applicant Red Line binder with
an Associated garage it is know that the
African is seeking to have the only
proved under a local needs Island and
others are unilateral undertakings would
have to be had done if approved the
application if approved would introduce
an l-shaped two-story drawing a little
1/2 story elements of South elevation
and then associated the taps coverage
the dwellings proposed to be constructed
natural stone
red brick which is going to be the 1
power story element stone quarries
natural a traditional stone millions and
Ron casement windows that's the second
elevational sheet
depicts in the front and the garage
floor pans as you see a full bedroom
gara dwelling and detached garage this
is a shot of the where it would be
located so from the local Road their
dining would be situated approximately
there
this is views looking dying so it's
quite rolling in landscape but you can't
see the edge of the village
once again this is now facing back
towards a Williamson Road
there is dwellings bound to the south
which is this construction there and
this is the property directly rear to
the boundary and gives you an idea of
the sort of local with an actor this is
really application shot and it shows
there is landscape and postal rail
fences on the boundary on conclusion
offer recommendations refusal it is
considered the applications not status
to actually demonstrate that there is a
clear identified local need for the
proposed housing which is a community
that scheme as a result the proposal is
considered representing an inaugural
form of development could not be well
integrated with existing built form or
sensitive to surrounded settings and
within just the encroaching to open
countryside role the resulting in
erosion of the law landscape there are
no updates thank you thank you very much
members these points out to you
obviously on our speaker sheet we don't
have anyone let's design the Parish
Council they had originally registered
to speak but have given their apologies
today because their representative is
unwell and unable to attend you will see
within the report their support we have
no objectives so it's over to our
applicant and war supporters I think we
have Jane catwalk and Sharon Wai ghin so
welcome to you both we have three
minutes assigned to you who's going to
do the speaking take the first minute
okay she wants us to give you a warning
one minute's up or are you just gonna
crack on okay I'll give you a 30-second
warning and in that case towards the end
and when you're ready over to you
I've lived a green Impala bullets and
since 2000 my husband passed away just
over five years ago and I'm left with
three children to bring up on my own
there are 17 15 and 13 my children I
love living and Willington and her
dominance here but we now need to
downsize our existing houses is too
costly to maintain my late husband was
deeply passionate about the village and
the chair of the parish council for
about 10 years
most of my parents live locally and I
wanted her to help care for them
including my father he has dementia I've
been on the council self-build
registered for every era I've attended
public prior to camp meetings twice
prior to submitting this application and
they fully accept my need and support my
application I'm proposing one self
thought Welling for myself and my three
children my adjacent father I understood
at my house would have legal agreements
to secure it for local people should I
ever decide to move and I'm fully
supportive of that
I realize it's difficult with two local
need scenes on this planning committee
and consistency is important but there
are differences between the two and I
wanted to set out why this dwelling does
meet policy and can be approved there
are two objections in the office the
report whether the proposal responds
dragon to bide need an official impact
in terms of identified need policy a s10
allows for small-scale housing to meet a
need identified by a local community in
a parish plan neighbourhood plan or
other form of local evidence Willington
is a tiny parish where know how they
need surveys being carried out there's
no parish plan and no emerging
neighbourhood plan the development
requirements SPD part s says evidence of
need will usually be in the form of a
local housing needs survey usually not
always paragraph s to point to point two
of the SPD and s 2.5 clearly allows for
needs outside a formal housing needs
survey the applicant needs to
demonstrate her justification which has
been done and you have certain heard
some of this needs written parish
council support this exists and would
have a legal agreement and complies with
other policy there are at least four
other applications in the district that
have been approved in similar
circumstances
answers contrary to the officer report
we have searched and there are no houses
in the entire parish not just Willington
which meets Sharon's needs with regards
to vigil impact sites not greenbelt the
not Conservation Area
not special landscape area and not a OMB
slide one on the screen shows the
proposed house is an attractive rural
design and well sited in relation to
other built form as shown on slide to
the previous application is not
comparable being an outline application
with no detail for two dwellings and
extended much closer to the road 30
seconds this is a good quality south
build house for a genuine local need
secured in perpetuity for local people
with parish and ward councillor support
no local objections no objections from
consul tees and it's what sustainable
development should be all about and if
I've got a couple of seconds and just
touching on councillor Perez point in
relation to the previous application I
had a conversation with the rural
housing and abler who basically said
that if a forum were to be filled out as
part of a housing needs survey then
Sharon would be an identified need so
that verifies your point about the tick
box exercise and that's your time lovely
thank you very much so councillor Perry
if you have a question good evening okay
in the report it highlights that the
officers recommended that a housing
needs survey was undertaken can you
explain why you decided not to go down
that route so a couple of reasons when
when I first met Sharon we spoke about
the application and looked at the SPD
for housing needs
SPD and the policies and we were aware
there wasn't housing needs survey
carried out by the parish the majority
of housing these surveys are triggered
by a parish rather than a private
individual and so what we did was look
at other applications which the
councillors dealt with in similar
circumstances and as I mentioned there
at least four which have been approved
where there's been no housing needs
survey carried out and parish council
and ward councillors support so from a
consistency point of view that was the
approach that we took
I think it's fair to say we have to
judge each on their individual merits
without the benefit of those in front of
us it's very difficult for us to apply
that ruling and anyone else have any
questions and many of our members know I
have a couple the justice he talks about
the local needs survey and justification
that you'd submit is but can you explain
to me what their justification is if it
could give me a bit more detail about
that please
so I say there's the two types of
justification the first was before
sharra engaged in the plan drawing
process and she went to the Parish
Council and sure she can explain where
she wants to but and the Parish Council
meeting to speak about her needs and the
Parish Council requested a full
application not outline they wanted to
see that the full details and they were
fully supportive of the application so
we have their minutes and that's being
submitted with the application and then
the other justification is inform in the
form of the applicant statement which we
submitted as part of the application and
Sharon's own specific needs which is
explained and if you want her to explain
someone sure she can I think that's fine
thank you are you registered on the
self-build register yes you are thank
you and I have no other questions unless
any other members have thought one no in
that case thank you very much for your
time now councillor O'Donnell is
registered to speak proudly everyone
seems to be ill or suffering today she's
unable to make it
she has however submitted her
representation to me which I'll reach
you now it is two pages long and I've
not had a chance to read it properly
before so if you'll forgive me while I
read from the paper so as you know as
you all know from from your sites visits
to the beautiful village of Wellington
this is a unique and special location as
what member I can report that it is a
close-knit community in Spygate and her
family are an integral part of this
community
whether it is in her taunted children
taking part in the animal
concert or helping at the village fete I
can sir Donald spoke at length of the
chairman of the parish meeting yesterday
and he has given me permission to recall
to in my robes nature representations
that the parish meeting are through
support of him is by gates application
of note is that my gates like husband
was chair of the parish meeting for a
decade such an investment of time
reflects a true dedication to protecting
and to nurturing a village from a
planning perspective please consider the
following factors the buy gate family
has strong links to Wellington having
lived there since the year 2000 there's
been a strong local support at the
parish meeting for the proposal and they
agree that the family need is a local
community need the proposal therefore
does provide for a local community need
there's also sorry there is only one
property for sale in the entire parish
at the moment and this cannot meet the
applicants need Rose bomb whilst
describers of four-bed property consists
of two bedrooms which are substandard in
size with regards to the technical
housing standards and are unsuitable for
shower for Sharon's children at their
age our own course actually allows for
local needs dwelling within or adjacent
to the village through CS 15 this
proposed dwelling has been designed to
meet the local needs being a
four-bedroom house it lies on land
adjacent to the village the previous
application was an outline with no
detail of scale or design now we have
full details the proposed is an
attractive well designed property of
rural character this is a similar scale
and and smaller than recent new builds
adjacent it would soon blend in with of
the landscaping there is a huge
expansion paddock to the front the
parking and hard standing has been cited
to the north so it would not be this
visually dominant in water views at the
parish meeting as the parish meeting is
small and doesn't meet regularly it is
not carried out a housing needs survey
with my Spygate bringing her need and
proposals to the parish meeting before
designer proposals and getting their
support I feel that this community lead
and is an appropriate solution to
providing for local needs dwelling where
there is no housing needs survey no
neighborhood plan emerging and no parish
plan it is also worth noting that our
own SPD states part s of the SPD bottom
of page 3 that whilst the district
council encourages parishes to prepare
and keep up-to-date housing needs
surveys surveys kemp and such surveys
can be costly and take many months to
prepare however like all technical
evidence housing needs areas of our
snapshot in time
new housing needs will continue to arise
in it and in exceptional circumstances
and need may be identified outside of a
formal survey for example for businesses
or welfare purposes in such cases the
applicant will need to demonstrate the
local need justification for the scheme
such justification will require the
written support of the town or parish
council and comply with other relevant
policy criteria including being
available to those with a local
connection this clearly indicates that
there can be cases when needs arise
outside over housing it means a survey
miss Bonnie gate has been on the council
self bill register for a year national
support for self builds is clear that
the SPD part J relates to self building
sets out that the government wants to
enable more people to build or
commissioned their own home and make
this form of housing and mainstream
housing option section 2a brackets two
of the Housing and Planning Act 2016
states that an authority must give
suitable development permission Emrys in
respect of enough service to plots of
land to meet the demand for self build
and custom house building in the
authorities area in each face period
this proposal is a self build local
knees dwelling which would be secured
for local people in perpetuity via
illegal agreement
finally SDC we have looked favorably on
self build in four similar locations
land south of the unwritten road in dine
skirt and cedar bungalow in Burlington
were granted through delegated powers
and land off Anton Road Blackwell and
land adjacent to Woodbine cottage
Blackwell were granted
Planning Committee in summary we have a
family keen to remain in and contribute
to both of the community and caring and
caring for the frail and vulnerable in
their family close by there is a local
need the buyer gates need to find
another property to call home in the
village having lost a parent so early in
life they need as little destruction as
possible and the community ties are even
more important than in usual cases
finally our policy supports such
applications and Spygate has listened to
the concerns raised with her previous
application and gone back to the
starting-point and returned with a
markedly different application I asked
you to look favorably on this family and
their application and grant and keep
your time so open up two points before
the officers council pairing County
offices that confirm the significant
weight given to the applicant being
placed on the south build register
please the South build register giannis
in this application would encourage
turns away simply because it to be
honest health care register you could do
it under any other policy criteria used
to have to meet our policy criteria so
even if it was make a local market well
in eating with the BIA be within a
village
you could still be on this health bill
register it has to be policy compliant
related to that I understand that that
the council is required to me as quota
for self builds and for that reason the
cyclic Ally a site allocation plan is
put forward to identify these that
hasn't been
as of yet you you know the outlying
number of self bills that are required
to meet the minimum requirement from the
and I would have to check what the
requirement was from the examination
what I can't say is the SPD is
supporting a number of sites for the
promotion of the south build sites
individual South build houses would
still have to be policy complied Thank
You members any other questions within
councilor Donald's report she talks of a
previous application can you just give
me an indication as to how these differ
if indeed they do and just give me a bit
of an outline about the the previous
application I think the best thing
quickly chose the previous applications
for which I have it under support second
so that's the previous application that
would refuse virtual committee so it was
outlying application for two dwellings
as you can see from like the other
slides resulting in Google Earth and so
forth it's still and all of a
settlements therefore it has open
countryside to certain areas Rio Nana
saw it shown in the photos and therefore
we like the principle which establish
and dwelling in officers recommendation
it's still their form of an encroachment
into the open countryside but the
difference is one dwelling from to
outline that was okay that's very
helpful thank you okay members and
exporting other questions for offices
let's move into the debate counter the
pairing Thank You chairman it would
appear we have a situation highlighted
in the report that there is a lack of
evidence because of we don't have a
housing needs survey which the officers
actually requested or recommended
according to this report that they
recommended that further information was
required for this on the basis of
precedent
but looking at this application totally
in isolation my view is to go with the
officers recommendation but also advise
the applicant that if if this was
refused that a housing needs survey
should be carried out and for the
application to come back at a future
time so therefore I am moving it to a
proposal to refuse in line with the
officers recommendation but it is with
regret
thank you very much so we have a
proposal caster Jennings I very much
regret second doing it
thank you anyone else want to have
anything to say in debate can say on
your cell phone I regret to okay I think
with a proposal and a seconder could we
please have a show of cards hands to
refuse the application in line with the
officers recommendation fortune for any
against and abstentions thank you in
that case convinced your resolve to
refuse application 1903 3 3 8 ful as set
out in the report Joe thank you so much
we will then in that case move to our
next item which item 7 that is
application reference 1902 76 to fu and
presenting officer is Sarah McPherson
who will join us momentarily
okay Sara when you when you are settled
there is no rush over to you Thank You
chair this is an application for the
demolition of existing buildings at
Doric works Studley an erection of six
three-bedroom Wellings the application
site is in the centre of Studley with
men identified here by the black dot
sorry identified here by the red line
the dotted pink line shows the
conservation area which society is
outside of the red buildings are the
nearby listed buildings of the church
and presbytery the black dot indicates
the site within the wider context of
Studley here's the site location plan as
you can see the site lies to the rear of
Doric house and is long and thin in
nature the site is currently occupied by
a factory and workshop which is not a
yes and has been unused since 2018 this
slide shows an aerial image of the site
and surroundings this photo shows the
site of the existing building it's a
long building so it can't be captured in
one photo but this gives an idea of the
existing street scene on that side of
the road and this photo shows the other
side of the road which is residential
dwellings mainly small terraced houses
these are the existing and proposed
front elevations you can see that the
dwellings are a traditional design
similar to others over the road
including small pitch roof dormers they
arranged in two blocks of three houses
and this side shows the rear elevations
as you can see from the site plan the
dwellings have benefit from a small
garden to the rear with space to store
bins and an ally to bring them through
as you can see residents would make use
of an existing on street parking area
this is the same arrangement as the
present Factory users which employed 30
people while it was fully functioning
this slide shows the floor plans for the
ground and first floors and this side
shows the second floor and the roof
plans it's worth laid to care that the
rooms in the roof are listed as home
offices we have planted them as a
bedroom for purpose of the application
to conclude it's recommended that the
application is granted in line with the
offices report as it is considered to be
a sustainable location for development
thank you thank you very much
moving to our first speaker than parish
council or town council can support
women your evening wasn't
Thank You ash you know the drill it's
the three minutes 30 second warning
whenever you already thank you had a
long speech ready for the first one this
one is not quite so long I think what we
have to refer to on this is something
that cancels a perry referred to earlier
on which is policy and precedent
district councils policy for development
like this is that the applicant should
provide parking for the property that
has been constructed the parking there
the on street parking has been used by
the residents in the houses opposite for
at least 60 to 70 years yes so if it was
used by the factory during the day time
for parking but in the evenings that was
always available for residents as you
saw from the officers photo earlier on
that is already used fully most of the
day time in the early day time the
school uses it for parking and people
picking the kids up from school and then
leaving the residence opposite who have
nowhere to park the applicant put a
report in on parking around the area and
suggested that the i-435 was a suitable
place for parking which anybody the
noticeably you would know that's a total
farce and unacceptable the parish
canceled have no problems with this
being developed it's a brownfield site
it is ripe for development but we think
the application that we've got in front
of us is not suitable in this location
we believe that there is room for
redesign and actually including parking
within the actual development itself a
couple of two or three-bedroom semis
with parking in front of them could be
fitted in here we're just losing a
couple of party
spaces on the front by allowing
residents in the new houses to park
there there is going to be conflict
between the existing resident and any
new residents that has already occurred
with the houses that are on the corner
they park there and there has been areas
where residents haven't been at a park
they've had to park on the road that
then causes issues with the traffic and
certainly at school times when you've
got mom's trying to come and pick kids
up from school the conflict of two-way
traffic there is quite difficult we
didn't even look at one type of turning
this into a one-way street so that
traffic could only go in one direction
but as it stands this it will cause
issues for the whole of the residents in
that street we think it should be
refused
and that can come back with something
that would actually not cause problems
for the residents thank you very much
quick question is the factory stern use
and if not when did it sees no it hasn't
been used for probably probably three or
four years there was a little unit
working in there doing catering for
about five years but the main bulk of
the factories not been used for some
time so ultimately what we're seeing
here on these pictures there's no way we
could argue that those cars are related
to the factory those are residents cars
they are all residents cars here okay
thank you members do you have any other
questions which has to be me
no okay in that case we haven't thank
you okay we have no registered speakers
on this item so straight to offices
clarification of the councillor Perry
can we just have some clarification on
the parkings its status cuz that would
be really helpful because normally
three-bedroom houses have to provide two
parking spaces per dwelling yep so as
I've said in my report this application
would require 12 parking spaces that's
two for each three-bedroom dwelling of
which there are 612 overall there is
parking to be provided within the
application site and within my report
however I have set out what I see is for
reasons why whilst not ideal it is okay
in this instance that no parking is
provided there in the report but I'll
just whip through them and Town Center
location being less reliant on the
private car the parking survey carried
out by the applicant showed there was
enough parking on the streets they went
twice once on a Sunday morning owing to
the proximity to a church identified a
capacity of one hundred and twenty two
spaces of which 61 were available and
again at half past midnight on a Tuesday
one hundred and twenty two spaces
available 66 sorry 66 out of 120 two
were available third reason highways
officer visited several times including
an evening visit and confirmed the
findings of the parking survey they've
also not objected we're also considering
for our fourth reason the alternative
uses if we're looking at the present use
as a b8 use that would generate a total
requirement of 14.5 spaces based on the
square meter which of the building and
our parking standards and the applicant
has also stated that when the factory
was fully functioning there were 30
employees which could be assumed to
generate more parking so for those four
reasons we think that was not ideal
that's okay in this instance thank you
very much sir hundred seven yeah I came
down there at 5:00 p.m. tonight and
there was probably four parking spaces
left I used to live red in the corner
and that's always been full of cars and
I just don't think you can accommodate a
lot of 12 cars and you might be more
cars if
resistors it's as far as I'm concerned
it's over development okay we were Stern
questions of the officers but I'm going
to assume we've moved to the debate
unless you have a response you want to
give briefing
just to clarify that the parking survey
it wasn't just Church Street and the bay
that you see in that photo there
included five zones which was including
Church Street two zones within a new
road and two zones within Oster Road so
it's not just that Bay that's in there I
can point out on a map so Church Street
obviously was included and then got the
zone
sort of this stretch of the road up here
this bit down here up here and down
there I could show you this which is a
bit closer so this section of the road
up here this one down here Church Street
up with the last Road and down there
hate shape it would be helpful if we
could see the Google map aerial view as
well where do that and we get a better
understanding of the actual development
around the area to give us highlight on
there the existing parking and the
factory that's gonna be it's a sting
parking bay goes from yeah I think it's
a bit of a break here from memory and
then there's a little bit more parking
here and then you can also park here and
I'm not sure about new Road and Ulster
Road and so just again if you wouldn't
mind show me the factory that is
proposed to be replaced yeah it's this
building here
just there it just shows the parking bit
bit more clearly so just not play the
parking bay is directly outside the
properties that would if agreed and
granted they be opposite there be a
meter or two walk yes I pitched it over
the road in my mind but I know yourself
opposite that's right hot for thank you
okay members do have any other questions
for clarification councillor Jenny I'm
afraid I don't know the answer okay
members any further clarification
appointments if not we can move into
debate councillor Perry
Thank You chair whilst the Posche
council makes some very valid points on
the parking I think as members we have
to bear in mind that we have some very
strong reasons that the officers have
highlighted and we also need to bear in
mind that if we were minded to refuse
this this would undoubtedly go forward
to appeal and on the basis that parking
surveys have been carried out and the
information that is in front of us I am
therefore minded to propose we grant
planning permission for this application
Thank You council Perry any other
councillors want to speak I will put my
two points in that case council ng
Seraphin has clearly made a point about
parking having had local knowledge
living there I don't
how long ago it was what concerns me
most is that these pictures clearly
these are dates is January 2019 the
factories closed I don't know what time
these are taken Acme we can one can only
assume during the day giving it a light
it's already round with cars I can see
the three spots at best and we're
looking for a well under normal
circumstances we might applied twelve
I'd know from experience in my own
villages just how difficult it is
there's so many people relying on a car
now and whilst the desire to move
towards a car-free development is a very
laudable one we're not at that stage yet
and there will inevitably be a number of
cars associated with this development
that My Mind's judging from these
pictures and the evidence I can see in
front of me now is insufficient we have
a policy and it's my view that we should
be enforced in that policy and on this
development so I wouldn't support your
proposal council Perry in fact I would
put a counter proposal that we refused
on policy grounds for parking the
insufficient parking that is available
based on the evidence that we're seeing
in front of us you know cancer Adam you
took the words right out my mouth I
think you've got a policy specifically
designed to allocate parking for new
developments and regardless of how many
parking surveys we do we still have a
responsibility to ensure those are are
met and actually worried about the
precedent there maybe set off the back
of not of allocating so I'd like the
second your counter proposal thank you
very much I'm just going to take some
influence from offices just both me
moment if you wouldn't mind counselor
yeah considering the parking and I've
lived in this village a long time and I
do drive down there quite regularly and
there's never very many parking spaces
and the belief that we can accommodate a
smaller amount of houses in there
because to me of site parking I just
don't agree with it at all because we're
struggling with car park in there so
that's my opinion okay thank you I think
I think it's fair to say that I've
agreed with that announcer house council
Adam we have a policy we have a policy
for a reason and I don't believe that
this fits that policy if something were
to come forward with sufficient parking
allocation we may be having a different
debate but that's not what we are we're
looking at this and what's in front of
us now I'm just refresh this is very
quickly summer for us before we take a
vote
thank you chairman a helpful debate I
think we've obviously identified parking
as that as the main area of concern for
members and also the representations we
received as it stands the application
doesn't provide on-site parking but
clearly that is also the case for the
existing use the parking situation has
been surveyed during the life of the
application whilst members are entitled
obviously to make their own decision on
the application clearly if we were to
refuse it on insufficient parking we
would be doing so without the support of
County highways obviously the officer
recommendation draws together all the
the issues in relation to the
development but certainly in terms of
parking has in fact in terms of our car
parking requirements there is a lesser
requirement from the development that's
being proposed now compared to the
existing situation that is
an underlying reason which underpins our
recommendation to you thank you gents
thank you very much
now we have to follow process and
process dictates that I must seek a
seconder for councillor Perry's proposal
before we move to the second proposal so
do I have a seconder for councillor
Paris proposals okay Thank You
councillor Jennings before we move to a
vote and legal officer would like to
have it was thank you just to highlight
two members that if your concern is
Highway Safety national guidance says
that you would need to be satisfied that
the effect is severe so just be sure
that you are well satisfied that it is
severe before reaching that conclusion
thank you very much I think it's fair to
say the debate has focused on parking
provision rather than highway safety but
I appreciate that clarification so we
have a proposal in a second to grant in
languages officers recommendation hello
please have a show of hands for those
who are supportive of granting a note
against three German in that case that
proposal is dismissed in that case we
have a second proposal which is to
refuse plan for mission for the reason
is outlined predominately parking and
parking issue do you need to go through
our reasons before we move to a vote or
are you satisfied that we have discussed
and debated it sufficiently
so quite specifically so my resolution
is clarify the reasons just so absolut
from my mind it is entirely parking base
to the evidence that's provided in front
of us what through these photos clearly
show that there is a huge amount of need
for parking and introducing further
development with out adequate parking
provision in accordance with our policy
is inappropriate that wasn't a very
eloquent way of saying why I trying to
say but I think you get the message good
thank you are you happy with that cattle
album as my second Oh marvelous in that
case can we have a show of hands who are
supportive of refusing for the reason
set out thank you for those againsts and
those abstain - thank you very much in
that case committee resolves to refuse
the application on mobile phone
application 1902 7.62 ful the reasons
stated okay moving now to our final
application of the evening application
number 19 0 1 2 3 5 fu Alice's land
southwest of Pithom Hall in even asset
Paul Thompson is our presenting officer
Paul take your time setup and when
you're ready you may begin
Thank You chef good evening counselors
good evening plays a Jonin we are now
here in Eyvind asset which is the
application site is the black dot in the
middle we're Eyvind asset is an all-over
settlement rather local service village
just on this planet about the topography
to the northeast and northeast range of
hills there this is closer in the
application of site is indicated with
the red line the red buildings are
listed the purple outline is the
conservation area and the green dotted
lines are public rights-of-way
the proposal is to insulate an access
into a hedge here and serve this land
and the land is currently unused there
is a pond here which the applicant
informs us it will be that works carried
out to that pond as a result of this
access being granted other speakers this
evening may refer to the driveway
serving with them all which is here
that's with them all there and then an
existing access to the land which is
roughly there I will not mention them
further because they are not a part of
the application before us so here we can
see the access in detail the green
markings of a hedge that is to be
realigned there is an existing tree
pretty much where the access is the red
arrows indicate the visibility splays
which the highways engineer has declared
acceptable in terms of highway safety
following the submission of survey data
services and so forth the point of
interest is the this Bend
here which is quite sharp it's quite
uphill and it's pretty much blind
the church here is on higher ground and
here we can see exactly that in the
left-hand photograph Abele demonstrated
by a cyclist at speed you can see that
the rise is here and effectively blocks
visibility albeit that the access is on
the side of the road with the best view
around that corner on the right-hand
side you see the view in the opposite
direction down to the other corner here
we can see the tree and the hedge that
will be removed and or realigned as part
of the the application both are
classified as category C which is to say
replaceable they are choked with Ivy
according to our bora cultural survey
and that is a nice picture in the
direction looking towards with them all
to summarize this is an access for
agricultural of maintenance use it's
intended to facilitate works that are
sure to deliver a net gain in dirt
biodiversity wants the right realignment
of the hedge in the removal of the tree
are taken into account the highways
engineer considers the access dimensions
and geometry to be safe following
amendments survey work and conditions
and counts the fielding has submitted a
comment on the update sheet which I draw
your attention and my recommendation is
at the Grand Planning Commission Jeff
thank you ever so much
ok and we will move to our first
speakers which is councillor Gill from
ape and asset parish council a big
chairman all she'd like to come forward
thank you for your patience this evening
do you have three minutes I'll give you
30 second one whenever you're ready
please go
thank you check by the end of this
presentation counselors will hopefully
understand the strength of feeling
within the community and why we would
like you to refuse this application
which was first submitted in May 2000
and 19 the officers report stated that
councilor fielding has made support
after reference to the monitoring
officer councilor fielding as has been
stated has to withdraw his support the
reason for this was councilman fielding
made comments at a parish council
meeting in October 2009 teen which will
refer to the monitoring officer the
report also states that highways of June
we drawn their objection
however it is silent on their conditions
it also states that there was no
objection from ecology but fails to
mention that they recognize the parish
councils concern over the removal of the
hedgerow it also states that the
proposed report passed brotherwe will
require no operational development we
disagree it also states there are ten
objections but one of the objections was
on Flippa the whole committee
representing seven properties we are
also evidence that this application is
objected to about 25% of the properties
in the village the application is
unnecessary as there is an existing
access that has been used for many years
when the applicant bought the land the
particulars our sale show a right of
access off the main stream without this
there would have been no access and the
owners of this access have confirmed in
writing to you that they are willing to
confirm that access is there and will
continue introducing additional access
will potentially generate further
dangers to road users and pedestrians on
an already perilous stretch of road
destroying significant hydro filling
treason
routing paralyzed simply to gain access
to a field will create an unnecessary
blot on the landscape of a conservation
area the traffic survey was completed
with an area and timing when there was
no school traffic that is significant
because in the school time there is a
significant increase in traffic on that
area of road accidents and near misses
that are not reported to the police
which is residents we are aware of those
incidents the parish council have
consistently objected to the application
for sound planning reasons our initial
objections were supported by highways
and ecology
it would appear that the applicant has
been encouraged to submit further
details in order to overcome these
objections councillor fielding and both
underplaying officer of both told us
that they were actively involved in this
process during your deliberations please
refer to the program prota graphs
provided and we would like you to refuse
it on the application on safety grounds
if however you are of a mind to approve
it we would request that you arrange a
site visit so that we can actually
demonstrate to you that the now opinion
the road is dangerous if following that
site visit I'm gonna have to ask you to
wrap up that is Soviet okay but thank
you very much in that case members do
you have any questions no in that case
nope you have okay you said there's an
alternative axis just real does the
element of the field only axis know the
local resident owns the access and he
has submitted a letter which I hope
you've seen confirming that there is
access there that is available to the
applicant and that will continue and has
been used for many years where is this
access in a safer position it is you
know much safer position yes okay thank
you okay there any other questions so
our next speaker is an objector as mr.
Biddle Stern welcome you have three
minutes okay
I think you've kind of got the gist of
things now so I'll give you 30 second
and when you're ready please okay
there's been an extensive amount of
correspondence in the past reports and
documents today I won't run through
those I'll simply focus on four issues
the need for the additional access the
visibility and safety issues the
existing access is already in place and
recommendations as well most of the work
that to be carried out in that area of
land is actually going to be short-term
and intermittent they're talking about
[Music]
managing the trees the grass and that
will actually be reasonably temporary
the only major work that has to be
carried out apparently is the clearing
of a pond and that in itself will be a
one-off event there is a question on the
road of the visibility and safety of
that however the maps actually look the
road is in itself and not even wide
enough for two standard cars if two cars
pass each other on the road one car has
to ride up on the
pavement to go past they've already
expressed the fact that they want this
additional access to allow large
vehicles in there now I fail to see how
those large vehicles will get in there
without riding across the other side of
the road and it will also be a slow
process to get a vehicle and a trailer
through across that access the
visibility for vehicles traveling up and
down the road is actually limited
particularly coming down the hill some
of the traffic service I saw gave
distances from the visibility on the
extreme right hand side of the road well
that's not the side of the road the
traffic sees the traffic comes down hard
on the left-hand side of the road so the
it would be much shorter distance before
you actually saw a vehicle crossing over
to get into that access there also on
that road as well cables
telegraph poles cables and electricity
telephone which in itself would actually
have to be moved and the question is is
it necessary for this intermittent work
there is on the other hand being the
existing access which is three point
seven meters wide it has a long entrance
to it which provides the unable to
accommodate a vehicle and a trailer on
the other way there is a clearer and
wider access onto Churchill with better
visibility up and down the road and then
it's okay for access has been accessed
in the past that's a sense the
recommendations are to delay or withhold
this planning decision to allow first of
all for discussion by the applicant with
the owner of that existing access point
and see if there's a conclusion to be
come to and that and secondly as has
been mentioned as well visit by members
of the planning committee to demonstrate
just how safe
how safe or unsafe I should say that
access new access would propose to be
that is spot-on thank you very much
remembers do we have any questions just
a clarification the existing entrance is
three point seven meters wide
the existing proposed for the new
entrance is 5 meters I believe but do so
with large large vehicles necessary
which way and identifiy we'll know this
but with large vehicles which intend to
use this to dig out the pond be able to
get through that three point seven
meters I mean I'm not an expert on that
but I mean three point seven meters is
the width the standard lorry a thing
I can't imagine I'm sure there are
larger vehicles that could go in there
but the question is is it necessary
particular for a one-off event okay
thank you
any other questions no in that case
thank you ever so much for your
contribution okay so we next speakers
are our applicants and all supporters or
agents it's Anita Burke our agent may be
accompanied by mr. Anderson this unright
marvelous now you have between you six
minutes are you going to split the time
or one of you be speaking your head say
questions
prophets okay in that case Anita when
you're ready you have six minutes I'll
give you a 30-second warning obviously
Thank You chairman and basically what we
want to sort of set out here is that the
applicants wants to create a and access
to a land which is an agricultural land
at McClain Eyvind asset and and the
purpose of this application is to obtain
a vehicle or access to the land that
would allow agricultural vehicles to the
land for the maintenance and enhancement
of the land which is in the middle of
the village the applicants need a
suitable access to take modern
agricultural vehicles to the land to
undertake the necessary maintenance and
livestock transport maintaining the land
has been very difficult for the
applicant without a suitable access
therefore the applicant has been has
submitted the application for
agricultural access to the land the aim
is to allow them to remove the dead
trees dredge the moat allow the water to
drain into the mode so that it can fill
up as per its original design and for
general maintenance of the land the
proposed access will allow the modern
vehicles to enter and leave the land
without which is designed to highway
standards the various works proposed by
the creation of the new access
regenerate net biodiversity gain in
accordance with the council core
strategy and in accordance with the NPS
and it is as we proposed a sustainable
form of development we have taken note
of the report prepared by the case
officer and we accept the conditions in
remove regards to landscape highways
archaeology
and biodiversity we've noted the
comments of the previous speakers with
regards to the alternative access reckon
answer any further questions with
regards to that we have had a look at
the access again this morning and it
matches 2.7 meters and it is narrow and
the applicants does not have a right of
way to use that to his land thank you
thank you very much both in time okay
members questions
councillor Jennings how why do you need
it
what's of a sized vehicles just I get it
ruff I do that access but we haven't got
access because we don't know access but
it's not as big as the Parish Council
that said 3.7 it's actually two point
seven which is a very narrow access that
is the access from the road which we in
the road is very narrow at that point so
we wouldn't better get a vehicle into it
and we need to get this is a beautiful
lake I want to restate my stall it needs
a big 360 machine in there to dredge it
all and there are a number of very
precious trees there so we want to
consider their beautiful trees have
little ducks for 35 years and I will
renovate the lake and make it beautiful
but we can't get machines in we've tried
to be polite for the people but we
couldn't get it through other ways
there's no other option and what
maintain it fantastic that's the power
my colleague is answered one of one of
them has asked one of the questions can
I just ask what sort of thing
have you undertaken any engagement with
the owner of the existing access yes
and we haven't got a right-of-way
through it and also we'd be coming out
in some the most narrowest part of the
village so careful consideration to put
this higher up says no houses at all
involved with it opposite the entrance
is a stone wall and there's no other
access or houses opposite objection to
the road further down it's a very tight
narrow
part of the village you would be
completely food from big machinery
through there because you can't get out
of it you can just about get in there
you know this is a Yuki 4x4 a wrap car
then you have to shunt a little bit
I've got clear pictures today of the
entrance and it is 2.7 meters wide and
we don't only access thank you we have
any questions from our on the left-hand
side
no key tell me what the field is used
for it won't so I've got to use we
create a sheet we would like to plant a
bit more trees in there we want to we
asked to put a footpath into the project
so people could use it but accounts
counsel said that was unnecessary also
we've got a big horse community like in
our area so I wanted to put a bridle way
in as well so they could wouldn't have
to go through the middle of the village
the bride would go across and see the
Lakeman renovated and make it a real hub
for the village it's a fantastic site
and I'm very passionate about it and it
will be one day restored and nice the
Sheep would graze on it now yep and the
plan will be to maintain sheep grazing
future take the sheep in out of the
field and cattle reduce it with a stock
trailer
I'm hence see so having a deeper throat
of it
how'd you get them in and out now
raising the moment out sorry I'm
confused so you do or don't have and
take it across into the field across the
rope to get and load it's very difficult
was easy you heard them across the road
okay that's what I was trying to look
sorry I think my emotions have bit hurt
members any other questions no in that
case thank you both very much for your
time
okay we will move to our officers points
of clarification the first thing I'm
going to do with herds that can you
confirm that we have we've seen sight of
that we have had sight of that okay you
haven't seen that I said okay thank you
members have you got any questions that
you would like to ask out so James that
the existing entrance is it 2.7 or 23.7
minutes just to get an overview of that
the training counselor haven't assessed
the existing entrance because that's not
the application but the hard work
highways have been objected to this at
all correct correction they objected at
some length but the amendments to the
scheme and the additional surveyed a
truth satisfy that objection objection
has been withdrawn now as engineers now
satisfied with with the access there's
no current objection that's right Cori
any other questions
now let's move to debates who would like
to start I'm going to pick on someone if
they don't put a hand up I'm gonna pick
on guys on the Left cuz I want to Kassar
Adam would you like to go first
I as there's no objections from highways
anymore which was my main concern based
on the comments raised from the local
parish council in residence I I can't
see and likewise yeah sorry um on that
basis I I can't see any reason not to
support it just by the local council so
I propose that we obliged I actually
agree with my other colleagues I think
that there are no material planning
reasons to refuse this it's particularly
welcoming to hear that the applicant
wants to obviously open up this land
restore this pond and create a bridle
way that will be used by community a
question
riders owners and with no objection from
highways we have no valid reason to
refuse this application fabulous I think
I completely agree notwithstanding the
comments that I made about an
alternative entrance we're not here
looking at the alternative entrance
we're looking at this application which
is for this entrance in this position
and without a house objection we have no
real plain reason not to grant so we
have a proposal we have a seconder can I
have a show of hands please it has to
grant in line with officer
recommendation
she anonymous channel so committee
resolved their fault - grunt - grunts we
don't often get applauded news
Savannah page in 1901 235 ful do we have
any urgent business none in that case
members Thank You members audience thank
very much
well close